hey 42 here it's November 2009 an
unassuming Saturday afternoon in the
heart of Venice unfolds just like any
other except for one small detail a
group of pull bearers are accompanying a
hot pink coffin down an overcrowded
Canal led by a somber faed man donning a
black cloak something has died not
someone but something the few remaining
residents of Venice are holding a
funeral FAL a funeral for the city that
was the permanent population of Venice
had just dipped below
6,000 half of what it was in the
1960s this was a public funeral put on
as a publicity stunt by activists and
residents of Venice to mourn the
supposed death of the city due to over
tourism as of writing this video the
population has plummeted even more
precipitously to just
50,000
Venice is one of the most touristic
cities in the world and this UNESCO
world heritage site is a fragile Place
most of the historic buildings are sat
on top of wooden piles driven into the
seabed with all that foot traffic and
endless boats stuffed with tourists
there is a very real risk that Venice
could be eroded bit by bit until the
very foundations of the city itself are
compromised but Venice is fighting back
in 2021 the Italian government banned
large cruise ships from entering the
Venetian Lagoon and in 2024 Venice will
begin charging every tourist 5 EUR per
day just to enter the city if they
aren't staying overnight Venice has
actually installed theme park esque turn
Styles at the entrances to the city near
the train station to control numbers and
enforce the fees leading some locals to
rename the city Venice land but all this
raises a moral social and economic
dilemma is this overwhelming amount of
Tourism a good or a bad thing does
tourism destroy a city by eroding the
local community and pushing up prices
for locals or does the money that
tourism brings in outweigh the
cons keeps is an online subscription
service that makes it easy and
affordable for men to treat their male
pattern boldness get expert care for
hair loss from the comfort of your home
without ever visiting a doctor's office
or Pharmacy and treatment plans are
personalized to address your unique
needs and treatment plans are affordable
typically half the cost of traditional
Pharmacy prices keeps offers both of the
FDA approved hair loss treatment options
as well as a two-in-one gel that
combines both treatments according to
clinical studies treatments offered by
keeps are 90% effective at treating hair
loss and can increase hair growth by up
to 35% in addition to clinically proven
treatments keeps offers hair thickening
shampoo conditioner and a styling perade
which I love most keeps customers will
notice results within 6 months of
starting their treatment and to dat
keeps has helped nearly 1 million men to
keep their hair they also deliver your
treatments directly to your door in
discret packaging and with shipments
every 3 6 or 12 months they work to your
schedule hair loss stops with keeps for
a special offer to get you started go to
keeps.com sl42 or just click the link in
the description that's ke ps.com
thought2 and a big thanks to keeps for
sponsoring this video tourism is one of
the most hypocritical Industries in the
world most people will mve off
incessantly about how tourism is a
plague on their city and regil about its
many evils then those same people will
go to bed that night dreaming of their
upcoming Vacations To Rome Barbados or
black
pool but what's the truth should we be
limiting tourism or should we be
squeezing every dime out of our cultural
centers and natural beauty spots well
the answer might surprise you and if you
watch until the end of this video you
might never feel the same way about
tourists ever
again our world is truly special not
only do we have more natural beauty than
one man can see in a lifetime but as a
species we've spent the past few
thousand years crafting a tapestry of
culture we have etched that culture our
Collective human story into buildings
buildings that have created cities
cities that have told stories stories
that have been retold through plays
books and films and shaped the way we
live our lives today so it's hardly
surprising that almost everyone has a
desire to go and see these cities
buildings and stories
firsthand International tourism didn't
actually exist at least not on a large
scale until the 18th century for
thousands of years people lived their
lives most mostly locally rarely
stepping foot out of their hometowns
then in the 17 and 1800s young upper
class men would embark on what is known
as a grand tour usually at the age of 21
it was basically the first example of
what we know today as a
gapar it was seen as a way to round out
a young man's knowledge and character
and instill him with culture in a way
that reading books just can't do oh they
also had a lot of sex along the way
truth be told that was probably the main
attraction Lord Byron was one of the
most infamous Grand tourists he spent
more than two years shagging his way
around Europe there were a few popular
routes but they almost always started in
London after a ferry to France the
spunky young tourist would typically
make his way to Paris leyon burn Venice
Florence then Rome but other routs went
through Germany and Austria or Spain
international tourism was restricted to
the middle and upper classes for
centuries culminating in the Golden Age
of cruising in the
1950s however it wasn't until the
proliferation of cheap air travel that
the working class could finally escape
the dreary British weather and even
dreier Seaside resorts for a spot of sun
in places like Spain Italy and Greece in
the 1980s and '90s budget Airlines such
as rire and EasyJet began offering
cheapest chip seats on short Hall
European flights
today you can fly from London to
destinations like Paris Rome and Berlin
for less than the price of your evening
meal when you
arrive over the following 50 years
tourist arrivals especially in Europe
exploded overwhelming numbers of Chinese
tourists in the past decade has also
been a huge contributor to these stats
since China's middle class has been
ballooning since
2000 of course it didn't take long
before these millions of tourists had a
profound effect on our planet take
Amsterdam it's one of the great cultural
and historic centers of the world but
the city center particularly the red
light district is now full almost every
night of the year with what have been
deemed as party tourists every day a
deluge of stago descend on this den of
the lights like sex crave Dennison
during the last days of Rome they litter
throw beer botles and other trash into
the canals start fights cause excessive
noise and urinate in places you wouldn't
even have thought were possible the
problem has grown so bad that the city
of Amsterdam has actually started an
online ad campaign to dissuade them from
coming I mean
arriving when men between 18 to 35
particularly British men search online
for terms like stago Amsterdam or pub
crawl Amsterdam they'll be met with paid
ads literally telling them to stay
away the Greek island of Santorini is
one of the most beautiful lumps of
volcanic rock on our Blue Planet it
isn't a surprise that 2 million people
come here every year but santarini is
also a small island with a population of
just
15,000 and the winding streets are super
narrow in some places only one person
can fit down at once and so a visit to
Santorini in the peak months results in
a line of thousands of people who are
literally queuing to walk down a street
furthermore most of the day Trippers
arrive at Santorini on a cruise ship
that pollutes the Azor Waters of this
otherwise Serene
Sanctuary Santorini is one of the most
instagrammed places on the planet but
behind every perfectly framed insta just
out of shot is an army of tourists all
pushing each other out of the way to get
the exact same
photo now you may assume that over
tourism is relatively harmless after all
we can can clean up the litter that
crowds leave behind we can repair
superficial damage we can do our best to
cleanse polluted Waters but if the trend
of surging tourist numbers continues to
increase as it has we might find that
those Marvels making people come in
their Millions might not last to Marvel
at for much longer because the world's
most visited tourist spots all have one
thing in
common really old whether it's
Istanbul's higher sfia Athens Parthenon
Egypt's pyramids or basically everything
in Rome and the problem with really old
stuff is that it's incredibly fragile
and all of them are now under a very
real threat of erosion from human
activity every year the Italian
government spends Millions on
maintaining and restoring the Coliseum
but there's only so much that can be
done ever increasing car traffic around
the ancient Amphitheater has caused a
layer of black Sut to form all over its
exterior which recently had to be
cleaned up at Great expense vibrations
from the daily hordes of tour groups
cause minor instabilities in the
structure of the concrete and travetine
walls and Floors causing very small
fragments to break off as dust although
minor over time this erosion takes its
toll and the more tourists that pass
through these Haring corridors the
faster it will crumble then there's the
unavoidable fact that for every 1,000
and respectful Taurus you're going to
get one or two see you next Tuesdays
like the two women from California who
only a few years back decided to sneak
away from their tour group to carve
their names into the walls of the
Coliseum now because they were highly
intelligent life forms they also made
sure to take selfies with their
handywork and upload it to social media
so everyone including the Italian police
could see just how magnificently
worthless humans they are of all the
historical artifacts matchu Picchu is
probably one of the worst victims of
human erosion UNESCO has recommended a
limit of 2,500 visitors per day to this
Incan Citadel but during Peak months the
actual number is more than double some
tourists clamber on the stones which are
vulnerable to being dislodged since they
were built without the use of mortar
which is ironically one of the main
drawers of this place
presumably the incor thought that
building Machu Picchu the best part of a
4-day hike away would dissuade most
people from visiting it but that didn't
bloody work did it if Taurus numbers
continue to increase Machu Picchu may be
a shell of its current state in just a
few
decades but Machu Picchu is symptomatic
of hundreds of other old vulnerable well
trodden SES all over the world from ston
hens to Petra we humans are slowly but
but surely stepping all over our own
history stomping it back into the ground
so what's the solution well there are
some options that often get bandied
about but the truth is I don't
particularly like any of them and I'll
tell you why we could firstly restrict
access to historic sites either by
Banning tourists altogether or by only
allowing researchers and academics to
visit them but I'm sure that you like I
would find it a little sad if only
certain individuals could enjoy the
majesty and wonder of the collective
history of our species firsthand such a
solution smacks of elitism and it would
result in only those with the right
connections or birth or from certain
Elite universities being able to enjoy
such
places personally I think that everyone
should be able to stand in the Roman
forum and breathe in the air in the
Beating Heart of the most significant
EMP Empire in our history every man
woman and child should have the right to
clamber over the bassal columns at
Giants Causeway and experience Mother
Nature's perplexingly precise magic
unfolding beneath their feet others
would argue that we should simply charge
people more to visit popular sites
tourist taxes already exist in most
popular cities from Venice to Barcelona
to De brnik couldn't we simply increase
these taxes and introduce similar fees
and destinations that don't have them
already shouldn't we vastly increase the
ticket prices to ring fenced attractions
like the Acropolis Sagrada Familia and
the Tower of London well yes we could
but it wouldn't solve the problem people
would still stump up the cash people
treasure their yearly vacations very
highly and for good reason for most
people it's their only escape from
routine and it may be the only reason
they work so hard in the first place if
they have the desire to go people will
find a way this solution is also very
similar to the last in that it
encourages elitism those who can afford
the new higher prices will still go
anyway and many of those who can't will
probably still go but it will just hurt
them a lot more they may have to take
out loans or put these new travel
expenses on highin credit cards travel
is already expensive enough as it is and
don't get me wrong it should be pricey
travel is a luxury not a right and there
are hundreds of people within the travel
system from taxi drivers to cleaners who
need to be paid a fair wage but we
shouldn't be artificially inflating
prices just to keep the so-called Riff
Raff out and to artificially reduce
tourist numbers by limiting Financial
accessibility people of all incomes and
backgrounds should have the opportunity
to visit at least some of these special
places at some point in their lives and
and what if I told you that almost every
argument I've made in this video so far
might be a straw man argument what if
over tourism isn't so much of a problem
but an
asset the media loves nothing more than
to chastise tourists writing damning
alarmist headlines about the damage
they're causing and live our lives
within our own four walls or else the
planet will be destroyed and Greta fber
will come around and whip you meanwhile
those very same journalist probably
enjoy their five or more vacations a
year jostling with the same crowds that
they railed against only a month earlier
in their weekly column because it turns
out that over tourism may not be such a
bad thing after all in fact the very
term over tourism might be a bit of a
misnomer here's why the biggest benefit
to tourism is that it's a powerful
economic engine and it provides some
locations with a much needed income
injection a whopping 10% of Italy's GDP
comes from tourism that's huge in Greece
it's
11.5% and Spain is
12.4% tourism is a huge creative of jobs
in countless towns and cities of all
sizes across the world only 50,000
people might live in Venice these days
but the tourism industry supports
70,000 jobs in the
city will soon charge day Trippers to
enter despite the fact that a whopping
30% of the city's Revenue comes from day
Trippers alone and that's not factoring
in all the other tourists who stay
overnight I mentioned earlier that sites
like the Coliseum are being eroded by
human activity usually from a
combination of foot traffic and vehicles
and don't get me wrong it is a concern
but do you really think that the
Coliseum would still look as magnificent
and relatively Unchained over the past
decades as it does today if it weren't
for the huge amount of money it
generates each year ticket sales alone
bring in about aund million euros each
year but it goes further than that
Financial consultancy firm deoe
estimated that the Coliseum actually
contributes about 1.3 billion euros each
year to Italy's economy it costs a few
million dollar each year to maintain
this building a fraction of what it
earns some of those who are employed to
work on it are World experts in
restoration stonework and archaeology do
you really think that this building and
many of us alike would be babied to such
an extent if it didn't act as such a
powerful Crucible of capitalism for its
mother
country and there's another positive
BYOD of Tourism that is often overlooked
by the
naysayers emotional power travel is
usually a positive experience and it
creates many happy memories
this creates an emotional bond between a
person and a place you get warm fuzzy
feelings when you remember that
childhood trip to Spain with your
parents perhaps your spouse proposed to
you next to the canals of Amsterdam or
Brugge or Venice or Birmingham and you
still said
yes maybe you just yearned to be taken
back to that summer you spent traveling
the Italian Countryside as you enjoyed
all the headyy Aromas and tastes that
you can still experience in your mind as
though it was
yesterday if you weren't allowed to or
couldn't afford to visit these cities
monuments and great wildernesses
firsthand we would never develop such
strong emotional connections with them
it's really difficult to fall in love
with the labyrinth in back streets of
Barcelona by just reading about them in
a guide book and because of a deep love
for and feeling of connection to these
places that we've been people regularly
and routinely donate money to repair
buildings maintain Landscapes and clean
up city streets people who don't even
live in said City International
organizations are also incentivized to
put money and effort into protecting the
places that people love the most such as
UNESCO icommerce and others you could
think of it like this by inviting the
world in to share these special places
it creates a global awareness and shared
love for those places which imbus them
with a sort of protective bubble when we
hear stories of people defacing the
Coliseum like I mentioned earlier people
lose their Collective almost every
major newspaper worldwide reported on
that story it's funny isn't it the
Coliseum is just concrete building but
it's universally loved and adored and
millions of people around the world
would have quite a lot to say and take
significant action if it was ever
seriously threatened and it isn't just
the big hit hitters the coliseums and
Eiffel Towers of the world that benefit
from
tourism there are small towns and
Villages dotted all over the globe that
are supported primarily by or sometimes
wholly by
tourism since the Industrial Revolution
a well documented phenomenon has been
taking place an exodus of smaller
population centers towards larger
population centers it still happens
today and it's a trend that shows no
sign of stopping when young people reach
working AG a large percentage of them
will up sticks from their sleepy town or
quiet Country Village and make haste to
the Big Smoke whether it be London Paris
or New York you've probably noticed it
yourself within your Friendship Circle
but tourism can help to stem that
bleeding it provides job opportunities
and even self-employment for people of
all ages in the places they grow up from
restaurants that are only open because
of the local tourist trade to tour
operators welcome to the Charming
Village of halat Austria it used to
enjoy a thriving economy from the
production of salt but demand dried up
and the town's very existence was
threatened however come the 21st century
this crumbling Community was thrown a
tourism Lifeline as interest surged so
did the crowds this town of only 800
residents now receives a staggering 3
million yearly visitors who flock to
enjoyed the breathtaking scenery on the
Skywalk descend into an underground salt
mine and stroll through the quaint Old
Town in 1997 hot was listed as UNESCO
world heritage site the locals might
despise the crowds today but they create
jobs opportunities and although they do
degrade the town they also indirectly
maintain it it's fair to say that
without them this town without any other
notable industry would be a shadow of
its former self and it isn't alone there
are countless similar examples all over
the world of places that have been saved
from the brink of Extinction by tourism
think of witby in the UK Brugge in
Belgium and Greece's
Santorini some people like to believe
that these historic places without
tourism can always look the same
function the same and remain as quaint
little fishing or farming Villages for
all eternity and nothing would ever
crumble or stop working and nobody would
ever leave and the locals would be
forever happy and well off and if we
could simply remove the tourists then
the status quo from 50 years ago would
return overnight but often that's a pipe
dream the world has changed industry has
changed the way we live work and travel
has
changed if these places didn't adapt to
and Panda to tourism some of them would
become dilapidated want proof before all
those budget Airlines came along in the
Victorian era it was popular for the
British workingclass to Holiday in
British Seaside Resorts like Blackpool
moram Margate real and many others all
of these places have seen a precipitous
decline in tourist numbers over the past
50 years due to cheap air travel the
British have instead opted to seek
warmer weather abroad which has
perfectly correlated with the social and
economic decline of Seaside resorts all
up and down the nation many of which now
struggle with unemployment homelessness
drugs and crime I'm not saying the story
would always be the same if you removed
a tourist from any town or city there
are of course countless small villages
and towns all over the world that thrive
with zero tourists but once tourism has
embedded itself into a community's
Prosperity one should remove that
tourism with great care because the
outcome is rarely a pretty one whether
we like it or not tourism is here to
stay the global population is increasing
the middle class is growing in
developing countries enabling them to
travel more than ever before so just
maybe instead of chastising tourists we
should find a way to balance our world's
precious natural and cultural heritage
with people's desires to experience it
firsthand if we can achieve that goal
then everyone wins and as a tourist we
should travel with great care and
respect for other people cultures and
places because the more we respect
others the more we will be welcomed to
new places with open arms instead of
placards telling us to stay away thanks
for watching just a quick word to say
that I couldn't make these videos
without the support of my patreon
members consider joining the exclusive
42 Discord Community by supporting in me
on patreon it's a great place to discuss
my videos with like-minded individuals
and myself the Link's in the description
but if you don't want to or you can't
join my patreon then please don't worry
a simple like or comment to say thanks
would also put a huge smile on my face
thank you